was anyone at the show where the
wrestler came on stage
you were oh guys so last time I was here
there was a guy sitting right where you
are okay and um I asked him I go hey man
I go what do you do for a living and he
said I'm a professional professional
wrestler so I said prove it
tell me a little bit about your
character tell me uh my turn
I don't have a whole lot of confidence
in this guy
and so when he came on stage I thought
you know we're wrestlers so we both took
our shirts off we were thinking about
going shirtless and doing a wrestling
move how do you feel about that yeah I
heard you called me out here and then I
saw you guys want to take your shirts
off so I'm probably just gonna go back
and um
and so I thought the first thing we
should do is talk [__] to each other
because that's what wrestlers do right
and I went straight macho man I was like
oh yeah
and he was not it didn't look didn't
have the body of a wrestler who was here
at that show
yeah not the body of a wrestler right
very like no muscle tone Lee sayat
titties you know what I mean like
so I was like oh yeah you got no muscle
tone you know what I mean we were having
fun talking [__] he was first of all the
worst [__] talker of all time I said my
stuff and he went yeah I'm Gonna Get You
and I was like you're terrible at your
job man
and then so I go what are you gonna do
and he said I'm gonna I'm gonna backhand
you to the chest and so if you've
watched wrestling you know part of the
slap part of the sound is the right they
do this with their feet
and so it makes it sound like a huge
smack and so he he did not do that
and as soon as he went back I was
thinking to myself
this was a bad idea
[Applause]
hey first of all
that hurt more than I thought
this dude and you can vouch for me how
hard he hit me he
remember in grade school
when they would have you make a turkey
on Thanksgiving
with your hand print I had a full five
finger turkey on my [__] chest can I
tell you how happy I am that that just
happened
I tested this I I love [__] that has
never happened to me I hope there's like
a little turkey hand on me yo you know
what he said I think I hit you too hard